on va passer au débat de ce club Messi
on va parler des cyberattaques avec une
résonance évidemment dans l'actualité
puisque on sera du côté du centre
hospitalier de Versailles dans quelques
instants mais d'abord pour poser le
débat Alex on va commencer par définir
ce qu'est une cyberattaque du début
alors une cyberattaque c'est une intacte
informatique qui peut avoir différents
objectifs voler des données désactivées
en système informatique ou encore
obtenir de l'argent les autorités
françaises recense 47 formes de cyber
attaque les plus utilisés sont d'abord
le hameçonnage c'est à dire qu'on envoie
un message pour inciter une personne à
communiquer ces données personnelles
bancaires en se faisant passer pour un
tiers de confiance autre forme de
cyberattaque le piratage c'est-à-dire
prendre possession d'un système au
détriment de son propriétaire et puis on
peut citer aussi le rançongiciel c'est
un logiciel malveillant qui s'introduit
dans un ordinateur le bloc est réclame
une rançon à son utilisateur ou encore
l'arnaque au faux support technique qui
consiste à une personne avec une fausse
panne informatique et donc à lui faire
payer un pseudo dépannage et quand on
regarde les chiffres Alex c'est un bon
des cyberattaque et oui en 2021 il y a
eu 1 million de recherche d'assistance
et d'informations sur le hameçonnage une
hausse de 130 neuf pour cent de piratage
de compte et de 95 % de rançons jiciels
la nature de ces informatiques elle
dépend aussi en fonction dépend des
victimes les particuliers sont le plus
souvent victimes de hamsonage qui
représente 31% des cyberattaques de
particuliers en 2021 les entreprises
sont plus touchées par les rançons
logiciels 24% des attaques qu'elle
subissent tout comme les collectivités
les rançon logiciels ça représente 20%
des attaques des collectivités merci
Alex pour ces chiffres Nicolas Arpajon
comment on explique déjà ce boom des
cyberattages alors déjà parce qu'on a et
c'est heureux des organisations privées
publiques qui sont de plus en plus
numérisés c'est à dire qu'elles
utilisent elles exploitent pour créer de
la valeur pour apporter des services
donc ça c'est la bonne dimension de la
dimension positive par contre évidemment
ça crée une dépendance à son
fonctionnement et donc les pirates qui
sont je le rappelle des entrepreneurs
comme les autres c'est à dire des gens
qui cherchent à optimiser leurs gains
réduire leur risque on fait en sorte de
se dire voilà comment est-ce que je peux
automatiser des processus je peux
éventuellement les internationaliser
c'est à dire faire en sorte que sur des
territoires assez vastes conduire des
opérations malveillantes et en plus on a
face à cette demande qui s'est exprimée
une offre qui s'est structurée donc on a
des outils qui sont de plus en plus
exploitables techniquement et
financièrement il y a moins besoin
d'être le de manière de comprendre
l'outil technique pour l'exploiter et
donc bah ça explique l'ampleur du
phénomène ce qui est certain c'est que
ça concerne toutes les instances qui
sont énumérisées et interconnectés
puisque vous avez compris donc par
exemple dans le cas de d'un hôpital
c'est que il a évidemment le
fonctionnement opérationnel mais après
il va interagir avec la médecine de
ville l'agence régionale de santé ou les
laboratoires d'analyses médicales et
donc effectivement
cette exposition au risque elle est
d'autant plus forte que si on n'a pas
suffisamment de moyens techniques et
humains pour assurer cette protection on
se retrouve dans un phénomène globalisé
un peu comme s'il s'agissait de se dire
quelqu'un on n'a pas pu empêcher
l'entrée de quelqu'un dans une maison
est-ce qu'on le cantonne à la pièce dans
lequel il est ou au contraire est-ce
qu'il peut naviguer à sa guise plus il
va pouvoir circuler bah évidemment plus
il commettra de dégâts et c'est un des
sujets donc les criminels vous l'avez
évoqué en fait ce sont des infractions
qu'on connaît historiquement le vol
extorsion le vol de ressources la
soustraction frauduleuse enfin toutes
ces dimensions là la seule chose c'est
qu'elles peuvent être amplifiées par un
individu s'attaquant à une multitude
c'est à dire que quand on était face au
phénomène des braquages de banque il
fallait au moins un braqueur par
rétablissement bancaire là on peut
démultiplier c'est ce qui donne
l'impression de massification du
phénomène évidemment sur le processus
sur la manière de s'en prémunir Louis
Hervé cyberattaque c'est un peu paraître
un mot un peu abstrait comme ça mais en
fait ça a des conséquences concrètes
dans nos vies d'individus dans les vies
familiales puisque on parle des des
risques pour les entreprises pour les
associations on peut parler aussi des
risques pour les familles ça existe dans
la vie quotidienne effectivement et je
crois qu'en complément de ce qui vient
d'être dit la vulnérabilité et d'autant
plus grande que la structure est petite
c'est à dire que même si vos exemples
sont des exemples de centre hospitalier
de grandes collectivités c'est normal ça
va
désorganiser un focus le fonctionnement
d'un service public mais vous avez dans
les PME vous avez dans les collectivités
locales de petites tailles de plus en
plus aujourd'hui de de voilà
d'organisation qui sont des structurées
qui sont l'objet de ces attaques là d'où
la volonté du législateur d'iromédia en
partie avec la locmi mais aussi avec les
actions politiques sur le terrain je
pense notamment à la prévention
parce que c'est aussi la principale des
réponses notamment avec les policiers
légendes qui sur le terrain peuvent
aider tous les acteurs à
être moins vulnérable on va on va
évidemment parler de la loopy de la loi
de programmation du ministère de
l'Intérieur et effectivement il y a un
sujet là-dessus est-ce qu'on sait
Nicolas Arpajon qui sont les principales
victimes et que cherchent précisément
les cybers alors deux choses la première
chose c'est quand il s'agit de récupérer
de l'argent donc de monétiser l'activité
on a vu une évolution l'évolution
c'était déjà de commencer à s'adresser à
aux propriétés légitimes des données
c'est-à-dire qu'une fois qu'on la
chiffré les informations que vous
détenez on essaye de vous les revendre
en quelque sorte en vous les rendant à
nouveau disponible après les pirates ont
vu que c'était pas forcément une méthode
qui fonctionnait très bien donc
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont fait ils se sont
dit bah en fait je peux chercher un
autre acheteur c'est à dire des entités
qui peuvent être intéressés par les
données collectées alors dans une
entreprise ça peut être des secrets de
fabrication dans un établissement de
santé vous avez compris les données
personnelles les données qui sont d'état
civil qui peuvent être utilisés pour des
opérations
ultérieures d'usurpation d'identité pour
des escroqueries et effectivement qui
ont donc une valeur sur des places de
marché donc là à ce moment là le client
recherché n'est plus l'entité
gestionnaire initiale ça devient la
communauté criminelle internationale qui
peut être intéressé par ces volumes de
données ce qui est certain c'est que on
a aujourd'hui la nature est le Caval
disait justement l'anti la l'entièreté
des entités connectées sont concernés on
a le cas notamment des collectivités ce
sont les fichiers d'état civil qui vont
être recherchés mais évidemment vous
l'avez vu avec les collectivités vous
avez les allocations sociales vous avez
les collèges les départements les lycées
ou les ou les écoles qui sont des foyers
de données qui sont particulièrement
monétisables sur des places de marchés
criminels
quand on regarde la protection des
données en général c'est ce qui nous
intéresse aujourd'hui mais la question
des données personnelles en particulier
c'est une Maroc je siège depuis 9 ans à
la CNIL on a une forme de déformation
puisqu'on va souvent parler de la
protection juridique en fait en disant
c'est pas bien de
ne pas protéger ces données personnelles
parce qu'on est gestionnaire d'un
fichier d'état civil du parce qu'on est
en entreprise et qu'on a un fichier
client mais la chose la plus importante
c'est la protection technique et c'est
aussi une des fonctions de l'autorité
administrative indépendante dont je suis
membre c'est d'aller regarder dans les
organisations comment de manière très
concrète on n'a pas le petit post-it sur
l'écran avec les différents mots de
passe comment on n'a pas sur un fichier
non protégé des mémos qui reprennent des
éléments etc donc des choses qui sont
assez basiques et qui vous évite de
tomber très vite dans on n'est jamais
assez prudent mais même nous-mêmes
regarde dans votre vie quotidienne la
galère que c'est que de souvenirs d'un
mot de passe tout le monde le vit même
moi et donc comment est-ce qu'on fait
pour et en fait c'est c'est là qu'on
commet les uns les héros des autres des
erreurs vous avez dans une autre dans
une PME le comptable qui est incompable
expérimenté qui est là depuis 30 ans et
cetera qui va tomber dans le panneau
d'un mail qui arrive qui ressemble
vraiment au mail d'un fournisseur qui
demande un virement virement est fait
parce que ce comptable a les comptes
bancaires alors qu'il ne devrait pas les
avoir etc donc en fait il y a je le
redis la preuve il y a l'intervention du
législateur ce qu'on fait ce matin avec
monsieur padjan qui est important qui
est mais c'est dans les organisations de
manière la plus concrète possible qu'on
peut répondre on peut on peut évidemment
prendre tout un tas de lois de
dispositions européennes françaises pour
lutter contre la cyberculanité on y
reviendra j'imagine
vis-à-vis des réseaux internationaux
parce que l'enjeu c'est que on parle pas
on parle peut-être du petit délinquant
du coin qui peut faire ça depuis chez
lui mais on parle aussi de résoudre
internationaux qui peuvent faire ça
depuis l'étranger
on va y venir évidemment mais
l'actualité on est rattrapé par
l'actualité et l'actualité c'est cette
cyberattaque au centre hospitalier de
Versailles on va rejoindre Richard
Delpierre bonjour merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous vous êtes mère du généreux
concours dans les Yvelines et qu'au
président de ce centre hospitalier de
Versailles qui est donc touché par une
cyberattaque depuis samedi elle est
toujours en cours
stabilisé mais on a perdu 80 % de nos
serveurs
dimanche midi donc
l'attaque a commencé à 21h les équipes
ont fait preuve de beaucoup de
réactivité ont eu les bons réflexes mais
commencer quand les applique commence à
tomber ça veut dire que le virus est
déjà là donc toute la toute la journée
de dimanche a été consacrée à s'assurer
que les malades qui étaient à l'hôpital
étaient en sécurité et pour les six dont
nous avons considéré que la progression
du virus pouvait les mettre en danger
notamment trois nourrissons ils ont été
évacués sur d'autres établissements
franciliens et alors je vous parle il y
a pas eu d'autres évacuations donc donc
le 1er message c'est l'hôpital l'hôpital
tourne il tourner au ralenti mais il
tourne et il tourne en sécurité les
personnels se sont très vite réadaptés
et ils l'ont dit il travaille en tout
cas sur la partie transmission de
données un peu à l'ancienne en mode
papier crayon mais voilà le l'ensemble
des outils qui permettent d'exercer les
actes médicaux fonctionnent voilà les
deux les deux secteurs qui sont qui sont
protégés entre guillemets ce sont les la
maternité sur lequel on a on a procédé à
des réductions de voilure pour permettre
d'accueillir l'ensemble de nos patients
en toute sécurité mais en tout cas vous
nous confirmez ce qu'a dit François
bonnet à savoir classique et la
continuité des soins et désormais assuré
François Brune il a parlé d'attaque
terrorisme vous employez ce mot
moi j'irai même plus loin je pense qu'on
est on est sur une nouvelle manière de
faire la guerre je ne crois pas beaucoup
au hasard ça fait en six mois deux
attaques de gros établissements
hospitaliers qui provoquent des
perturbations extrêmement importantes
sur le fonctionnement de notre système
de santé et vous savez quand on quand on
a géré une crise tous ceux qui s'en
occupent s'inquiètent évidemment de la
surprise
voilà le il y a une dimension
emblématique
ce qui nous attaquent et je ne sais pas
qui le sont veulent montrer qu'ils
peuvent taper au cœur du système et je
crois qu'il va falloir qu'on s'interroge
et qu'on n'attend pas la troisième
quatrième attaque d'un grand centre de
soins pour se dire que cette partie là
de de de notre notre patrimoine doit
être protégé sans doute aussi de manière
aussi importante que le sono central
nucléaire ou un certain nombre de points
de système de défense nationale je c'est
mon intime conviction et je crois qu'il
fallait il ne faut pas attendre d'avoir
de nouvelles attaques sur ces gros
établissements sans doute sont-ils je
l'ai entendu mieux protéger que nos PME
mais voilà on touche au cœur de notre
système de santé il y a des vies qui
sont en jeu là les équipes ont très qui
agit nous n’était pas à l'abri de perdre
des vies humaines
donc on est sur quelque chose
d'extrêmement sensible et je pense qu'il
va falloir très rapidement
revisiter la manière dont on protège nos
établissements l'épisode qui a eu à
corbeille cet été a commencé déjà à
aider à cette prise de conscience et
voilà je pense qu'il va falloir qu'on
accélère le rythme les moyens qu'on y
consacre pour permettre à la fois nos
établissements de santé de continuer le
délivrer délivrer service mais de pas
vivre avec cette épée de démoclès
au-dessus de la tête de se dire que
parce qu'ils sont interconnectés ils
sont hyper vulnérables on le sait le
retour à la normale va prendre du temps
beaucoup de temps plusieurs mois et et
nos équipes même si elles sont
résiliantes sortent de deux années de
covid et voilà donc je pense qu'il faut
il faut qu'on s'interroge collectivement
sur les moyens qu'on met pour mieux
protéger les les gros hôpitaux qui qui
commandent et qui qui délivre le gros du
service public de santé sur nos
territoires vous n'avez aucune idée de
qui et derrière cette attaque est-ce
qu'elle a été revendiquée il y a eu une
demande de rançon qu'a
ne pas la payer ça c'est une certitude
après on va laisser les enquêteurs de
l'engendarmerie faire leur travail on
sait que dans cet univers là c'est
extrêmement difficile de remonter de
remonter la piste ce que j'espère c'est
qu'on pourra nous dire si la la
technicité utilisée par les assaillants
et de haut niveau et si on est sur autre
chose que du bricolage ou de ou du
travail de géniaux à coeur j'en ai là
j'en ai moins l'intime conviction mais
c'est vraiment le travail des gendarmes
et la justice que de nous éclairer
autant qu'il le pourront sur sur la
nature de ces attaques sur leur
caractère structurés et sur le caractère
répétitif on verra notamment si entre
l'attaque de corbeille il y a des
similitudes ce sera un élément éclairant
je pense merci beaucoup merci Richard
Delpierre d'avoir été avec nous-mère du
généreux concours et donc qu'au
président de ce centre hospitalier de
Versailles vous vous l'avez entendu Loic
Hervé il parle d'une nouvelle forme de
guerre ça va au-delà de l'attaque
terroriste dont tu as parlé François
Braun pour Richard Delpierre et il dit
il y a les hôpitaux finalement ne sont
pas suffisamment protégés vous êtes
d'accord avec tout ça
par exemple on voit bien que il y a un
défaut de protection de nos hôpitaux
effectivement la situation
internationale peut tout à fait avoir
comme conséquence des attaques sur un
certain nombre de nos infrastructures je
pense notamment aux infrastructures ça
fait mal un hôpital ça désorganisé un
système de santé si on est sur une forme
de guerre psychologique c'est plus c'est
très parlant vis-à-vis de l'opinion
publique je crois qu'une des choses qui
est très révélateur de ce que Monsieur
le Maire a évoqué c'est la préparation
ou l'impréparation à la résilience
c'est-à-dire qu'en fait
l'informatisation des processus
notamment dans la santé mais c'est vrai
dans d'autres organisations fait qu'on
il y a pas de machine arrière possible
ou du moins ça demanderait un effort et
ça demande un effort d'entraînement qui
fait dans les forces armées par exemple
si on devait être coupé par exemple de
des réseaux hertziens du GPS
les armées je pense notamment à la
marine apprend toujours à
piloter un navire avec
les la culture historique dans un
hôpital on passe au papier au crayon
mais pas aussi simple que ça il y a tout
ce qui a été informatisé y compris une
grande partie de la connaissance manque
donc c'est très important aussi d'avoir
une forme d'entraînement à la résilience
c'est-à-dire de se dire si on avait une
coupure de courant importante
et que par exemple les dispositifs de
secours ne se mettent pas en marche si
on a une attaque cyber qui dure qui peut
durer parce que le temps de recouvrer
l'intégralité de ces données de ces
processus ça prend du temps
indépendamment du paiement de l'argent
parce que le pays combien même l'hôpital
aurait payé la rançon c'est pas sûr
qu'il récupère ses données de prendre
premièrement et deuxièmement le le mal
est fait et le mal est grave dans
l'organisation donc ça demandera du
temps donc c'est ça c'est très important
oui la situation internationale
incontestablement un un à des
conséquences sur ces attaques en France
c'est une et en Europe c'est une
évidence mais il y a aussi la question
de comment on répond à ça y compris par
l'entraînement et par la résilience
comment on y répond comment on se
prépare et est-ce que vous dites vous
aussi qu'on est dans une nouvelle forme
de guerre alors pour serrer les réponses
après s'y préparer il y a deux
investissements technologiques et
humains les Nizas c'est l'Agence
européenne de cybersécurité qui est pas
le plus comment dire justement pousse au
crime dans ce domaine là constate quand
même que globalement les établissements
de santé ont des niveaux
d'investissement inférieur au reste en
clair il faudrait pour bien avoir les
ressources suffisantes avoir 15% du
budget numérique c'est-à-dire système
d'information consacré à la
cybersécurité on est plutôt aux
alentours de 7% dans le cas des
établissements de santé c'est une partie
de l'explication deuxièmement ce sont
des pénuries personnelles parce que non
seulement il faut des outils mais il
faut pouvoir les déployer et les et
piloter de manière à les adapter aux
changements d'environnement la guerre
alors dans je vois bien le propos
ministériel autant on peut concevoir
d'ailleurs on l'a vu dans le cas de
l'Ukraine physiquement c'est-à-dire que
l'agresseur russe a utilisé l’arme
numérique pour précéder les invasions
physiques c'est-à-dire de manière à
créer des dysfonctionnements des
perturbations ah non pas douter dans ce
cas-là je pense qu'on est quand même
d'abord dans une attaque crapuleuse même
si pour les attaquants la cible d'un
établissement public n'est pas
profitable pourquoi parce que comme il y
a cette doctrine de ne pas payer les
rançons et maintenant de l'autorité
publique et puis il y a aussi
l'insolvabilité il faut être très clair
le budget de je crois que le maire de
l'établissement de Versailles a décidé
de ne pas solliciter le montant de la
rançon le qu'on ne sait pas qui était
mais on peut envisager que si on compare
au regard de la taille de cet
établissement globalement ça aurait été
qu'ils ont deux millions d'euros en
crypto monnaie dans le cas de corbeille
c'était 10 millions dans la demande
initiale descendue à un million après à
bref échanges vous voyez bien que ce
n'est pas dans des ressources
disponibles de la part d'un
établissement public surtout qui devrait
dans sa comptabilité sortir en crypto
monnaie ce qui ne lui permet pas en
principe la comptabilité publique mais
ça veut dire là pour qu'on soit clair
dans ce cas-là en tout cas vous ne
croyez pas une attaque géopolitique
alors je pense que dans ce cas-là la
géopolitique s'accompagnerait
d'opération d'agide props c'est-à-dire
faire en sorte de donner une
dramatisation de faire en sorte qu'il y
ait une mise en contexte une mise en
cause des autorités avec des messages
avec une dramatisation et là vous êtes
dans une stratégie déployée je crains
que dans ce cas-ci on soit dans une
banale
automatisation de système qui
intègre les établissements de santé
parmi cela et qui en plus faisait que je
vous dis d'un point de vue strictement
crapuleux c'est pas forcément très
performant ça n'empêche que ça crée des
dysfonctionnements et que évidemment et
l'unité de compte parce que hélas on a
évoqué corbeille mais on a eu d'Ax avant
on a eu Villefranche-sur-Saône c'est on
a on l'a déjà atteint la demi-douzaine
de grands établissements l'unité de
compte c'est plutôt l'année pour revenir
à une situation normale par contre
évidemment et c'est là où les
gestionnaires publiques ont des
obligations en termes de recrutement en
termes d'investissement et de
déploiement de solutions de sécurité qui
existent des annonces ont été faites
mais là encore dans la cyber les
annonces de création de poste ont pu
être faites il va falloir les convertir
en recrutement effectif c'est-à-dire
vous pouvez ouvrir des postes mais s'il
n'y a pas les candidats vous ne pouvez
pas les fidéliser c'est la limite de
l'exercice c'est là où on va retomber
dans des problématiques de management
d'attractivité très humaine technique
certes mais ne pas négliger la dimension
humaine et de se doter d'outils qui
soient cohérent avec la situation
technique des établissements de santé on
parlait des établissements de santé mais
collectivités sont également touchés
notamment avec le déploiement du
télétravail et du tout numérique le
conseil départemental de séné-marne a
été victime d'une cyber-attaque de
grande ampleur le 7 novembre dernier et
depuis les services informatiques sont
paralysés on regarde sur le reportage de
Flora sauvage
écran noir téléphone hors détails et un
système informatique totalement paralysé
depuis le 7 novembre le conseil
départemental de Seine-et-Marne est
victime d'une cyberattaque de grande
ampleur responsable du service
comptabilité Christophe Noël a dû
revenir à l'usage des factures papier à
l'image des 5000 agents employés par le
Département c'est l'ordre de paiement
manuscrit qu'on a mis en place du coup
avec la collaboration de notre payeurs
que les directions doivent remplir du
coup pour pouvoir mettre en paiement
toutes les factures et toutes les
allocations doté 5 milliards d'euros le
Conseil départemental est notamment
chargé du versement de l'allocation aux
adultes handicapés du RSA ou encore de
la location personnalisée à l'autonomie
et puis maintenant 4 semaines c'est très
compliqué pour nous de travailler
puisque nous sommes un peu coupés du
monde on n'a pas de téléphone pas de
messagerie pas d'internet donc il a
fallu qu'on trouve des solutions pour
s'adapter et continuer à communiquer
notamment entre collègues il a fallu
qu'on trouve un moyen palliatif pour
continuer ses paiements donc on continue
télécharger les factures mais on est
obligé aujourd'hui de les imprimer de
les envoyer aux directions en version
papier qui doivent rédiger
manuscritement des ordres de virement
du conseil départemental de
Seine-et-Marne n'apportait plainte il
craint que les hackers et récupérer des
données personnelles je pense à nos
agents puisque leurs coordonnées
bancaires peuvent avoir été hackés mais
comme les coordonnées bancaires aussi de
l'ensemble de nos bénéficiaire du RSA de
l'appart de toutes les allocations dont
sont indépendants à ce stade je suis
incapable de vous dire qu'ils ont été
les fichiers qui ont été détournés ou
autres je n'en sais rien une rançon de
10 millions de dollars a été réclamé
mais le Conseil départemental refuse de
payer en attendant l'urgence pour les
informaticiens et d'analyser post par
poste l'étendue des dégâts la salle du
Conseil a été transformée en cellule de
crise un travail de fourmis pour les 70
agents qui sont sur le pont depuis un
mois la première faille c'est
généralement l'utilisation de ce qu'on
appelle le fishing c'est à dire de mails
qui sont le guide mot de passe qui sont
attrapés par les hackers par justement
parfois des mauvaises pratiques de nos
utilisateurs avec le déploiement du
télétravail et la numérisation
grandissante des services aux usagers
des collectivités territoriales sont
devenues les cibles des pirates
informatiques comme l'expliquent cette
experte en cybersécurité c'est comme
dans une rue dans une rue vous prenez
différentes maisons les attaquants vont
regarder les portes bien protégées les
blindés elles vont passer à côté elles
vont celles elles vont vers celles qui
sont moins protégées et bien c'est
pareil sauf que là ça a touché des
collectivités territoriales et des
hôpitaux alors qu'on pourrait se dire
que attaquer pour des rançons c'est pas
l'endroit où on a le plus d'argent à
retirer on pourrait se dire que c'est
plutôt des grandes structures en grande
entreprise qui pourraient payer or la
règle c'est de ne pas payer les rançons
et en tout cas c'est les données qui
sont dans les collectivités qui sont la
priorité devant la recrudescence des
cyberattaques les collectivités locales
tentent de mieux se préparer en
investissant dans des systèmes de la
sécurisation de leur système
d'information si leur est difficile
d'empêcher une nouvelle attaque
l'objectif est bien de limiter au
maximum les intrusions par des pirates
informatiques et on le voit le café il a
été question dans son pour qu'on soit
bien clair est-ce qu'une collectivité ou
est-ce qu'un hôpital peut payer une
rançon est-ce que c'est légal vous savez
que dans un hôpital public comme dans
une collectivité locale il y a un
principe qui est la séparation de
l'ordinateur et du compte à l'ordinateur
fait souvent les îles locaux et le
comptable étant un agent de Bercy et
évidemment aujourd'hui dans la doctrine
actuelle dans le sphère publique pour
l'État pour ces établissements publics
pour les collectivités locales comme
dans l'autre domaine hospitalier il
n'est pas question de payer évidemment
cette rançon pour des raisons de
comptabilité publique même si sur un
plan
théorique ça pourrait se faire mais ça
ça demanderait à s'attendre de choses
que qui n'est absolument pas pratiqué
moi je pense que c'est et je pense que
c'est bien parce que c'est bien parce
que si on si dans notre pays les centres
hospitaliers ou les collectivités
locales se on rentrait dans un autre
dans un autre dans une autre phase de de
la des conséquences de la
cybercriminalité
voilà donc je pense que c'est il faut
rester là donc en fait c'est 20 de
demander une rançon à un hôpital un
établissement public c'est pour ça que
ce que je disais tout à l'heure au point
du crapuleux ce n'est pas performant par
contre ce qui est certain c'est que
l'entre des entreprises sont amenées à
payer et donc c'est ce qui donne le
caractère profitable de cette activité
par contre le pirate a donc intérêt à
élargir le nombre de victimes de manière
à optimiser le taux de transformation de
celle qui vont accepter de payer
finalement la rançon on va aussi dans
une question qui se pose à travers ce
reportage c'est la question du dépôt de
plainte le Ikea est-ce qu'il est
systématique le développement c'est une
évolution importante de la loi
au terme de la loopnie nous avons trouvé
un accord avec les députés la semaine
dernière et cette loi va être votée la
semaine prochaine
l'idée du législateur et de conditionner
le l'assurance le remboursement
d'assurance la prise en charge par
l'assurance au dépôt de plainte le plus
rapide possible donc dans la créé dans
la loi un délai qui permet qui oblige
ceux qui sont l'objet d'une attaque à à
se signer des pourquoi
et on vise notamment les entreprises il
y a des entreprises qui travaillent dans
le domaine de la défense dans le domaine
de la sécurité qui sont parfois clés des
entreprises vraiment sensibles qui ne
veulent pas au titre de leur réputation
qu'on sache qu'elles ont été l'objet
d'une attaque et on peut le comprendre
simplement si on veut répondre notamment
sur un point de vue de l'enquête et de
la lutte contre la criminalité il est
nécessaire que les cybers gendarmes et
les cyber policiers et connaissances de
ces attaques le plus tôt possible c'est
une course contre le temps donc il y a
une urgence dans l'entreprise mais aussi
une urgence pour ce qui a des pouvoirs
publics et notamment des forces de
sécurité de pouvoir réagir donc
l'obligation de cette de ce dépôt de
plainte est une manière pour les
enquêteurs de connaître au niveau
national ce qui est en train de se
passer puisque vous avez des attaques
parfois qui sont des attaques
simultanées de tout un tas de
d'organisation donc une espèce de
d'importance de connaissances et donc on
a lié l'assurance avec le développement
un mot Alexandre de cette programmation
de ministère de l'Intérieur puisque les
moyens ont été mis sur la cyber
délinquance effectivement cette loi
prévoit 8 milliards d'euros pour la
lutte des forces de l'ordre contre les
cybermonaces 8 milliards d'euros sur 5
ans avec d'autres mesures à une école de
formation à la cybersécurité créée au
sein du ministère de l'Intérieur un
numéro de signalement des cyberattaques
va être mise en place le 17 cyber c'est
l'équivalent du 17 pour appeler la
police et plus de 1500 cyber cyber
patrouilleurs qui vont être déployés sur
le net des moyens de cyber enquête sont
également renforcés sur autorisation de
la justice la police pour enquêter sur
le net sous pseudonyme saisir des actifs
numériques des personnes soupçonnées et
puis pour les rançons logiciels vous le
disiez Louis Carvin le remboursement
d'une rançon par une assurance d'une
entreprise doit être conditionnée au
dépôt d'une plainte en moins de 48
heures puisque certaines entreprises
avaient tendance à payer des rançons
sans tes plans Nicolas va est-ce que
pour vous les moyens mis en France sont
suffisants où est-ce qu'on est en retard
sur cette question de lutte contre la
France a posé avec la réglementation
depuis on a eu une loi de programmation
militaire qui a permis d'établir ce
qu'on a désigné comme étant des
opérateurs d'importance vitales à peu
près une de plusieurs centaines
d'entreprises
issus de 12 secteurs d'activités donc
les télécoms le train l'eau
l'alimentation service financier etc qui
ont permis de fixer des obligations
c'est-à-dire évidemment ça empiète un
peu sur l'autonomie du dirigeant
l'entreprise parce qu'on lui dit voilà
votre activité est considérée comme
critique ça a été confirmé renforcé par
une directive européenne la directive
Nice également entrée en vigueur en 2018
dont la deuxième version vient d'être
également finalisée il faut le
reconnaître grâce au travail aussi de la
du vraiment général sur la protection
des données parce que lorsque les
commissaires à la protection des données
prononcent des sanctions pouvant aller
jusqu'à 4% du chiffre d'affaires mondial
globalisé d'une entreprise bah en fait
ça met un prix sur la valeur des données
et donc on se dit bah si on ne veut pas
être en infraction surtout que les
données personnelles c'est en général
les données de vos collaborateurs ou les
données de vos clients c'est-à-dire ceux
pour lesquels en principe vous avez des
marques de considération en tout cas
dans votre politique marketing et donc
ça veut dire que vous êtes obligé
d'investir parce que vous avez des
moyens alors évidemment la
réglementation c'est un agenda des
cahiers des charges et éventuellement un
régime de responsabilité de sanction bah
ça a permis de d'avancer sur ces sujets
là par contre on bute sur deux
problématiques les compétences les
compétences les compétences pourquoi
parce que tout le monde recrute
administration civile de l'État
administration militaire grandes
entreprises fournisseurs de services PME
et puis le monde criminel également donc
on a une pénurie de candidats et ce qui
crée une tension on peut c'est pour ça
que je faisais le distinguer entre on
peut annoncer la création de poste il
faut ceci soit pourvu et qu'ensuite il
faut que ces personnels soient fidélisés
c'est un domaine où il faut former et
former tout au long de la vie on peut
pas considérer que la connaissance
réacquise une fois un diplôme initial
obtenu donc ça veut dire qu'il y a un
défi aussi très managérial de tous les
recruteurs privés publics qui ne se
traduit pas uniquement par des annonces
budgétaires ouais et puis évidemment le
Parlement a voté une loi pour enfoncer
les moyens dans le pays mais est-ce que
ça passe par une nécessaire coopération
internationale coopération
transfrontalière avec Hervé
plus européenne
si on peut on peut on peut pas dire que
ce soit le le
la dimension qui soit qui fonctionne le
moins bien
les coopérations entre services de
police ou au travers de la travers
l'Atlantique ou en Europe sont plutôt
alors ça peut toujours s'améliorer
évidemment mais bien sûr que le
déploiement de moyens à l'échelle de la
loopnie c'est en plusieurs milliards
d'euros sur cinq ans et les questions de
coopération nationale sont vraiment les
les éléments sur lesquels on peut aussi
répondre c'est encore une fois la
question d'une question de rapidité dans
dans l'organisation quand l'air doit
donner au plus vite pour limiter au
maximum les dégâts et aussi l'alerte aux
policiers gendarmes 48 heures c'est très
court 48 heures quand vous avez pris
conscience que c'est une cyberattaque le
fait de pouvoir alors que vous êtes
affairé plutôt à regarder ce qui se
passe dans votre entreprise ou dans
votre organisation publique
la question de la du développement elle
est pourtant une des premières choses à
faire
en disant quête polish gendarmerie vont
respecter les codes le code de procédure
pénale donc et vous l'avez bien vu le
café a parlé de coopération le FBI quand
on dit est-ce que RuPaul c'est le FBI
européen non pourquoi parce que le FBI
c'est un même système juridique une même
langue sur un territoire de 350 millions
d'habitants l'Union européenne Europole
c'est de la coopération policier
français parlent à son collègue
également qui parle à son collègue
italien donc évidemment ça reste un
territoire juridiquement morcelé en tout
cas judiciairement morcelé qui fait que
c'est un privilège pour les pirates qui
eux peut faire du saut de frontière en
quelque sorte pour se dissimuler ils ont
la vélocité liée au numérique
c'est-à-dire de déplacer leurs
équipements leurs infrastructures
pourquoi c'est pour ça que le dépôt de
plainte est important les recrutements
aussi côté police parce que plus il y
aura des potes plus à convaincra le
législateur que le sujet a une
matérialité pour rappeler le parquet de
Paris de magistrats dédié à cela avec
deux enquêteurs spécialisés pourtant ce
sont de grands professionnels mais ça
reste des moyens disproportionnés
de l'ampleur de l'attaque merci pour vos
éclairages passionnants messieurs sur ce
sujet
[Musique]